nous allons tous gagnés à casser le
modèle patriarcal
parce qu'ils demandent aux hommes d'être
surhumains et évidemment ils ont besoin
d'exutoire à cet effort permanent à
cette espèce d'efforts prométhéen
malsain et puis il met en danger des
femmes donc nous avons tous intérêt
hommes et femmes garçons et filles à
casser ce modèle patriarcal il ne permet
à personne de s'épanouir
christiane taubira bonjour vous êtes une
femme politique vous avez été député
ministre de la justice entre 2012 et
2016 mais vous êtes aussi écrivaine et
vous publiez justement un recueil de
nouvelles c'est votre premier dans
lequel vous livrer des morceaux de vie
parmi ces histoires y en a une qui m'a
marqué c'est celle de magna c'est une
jeune femme dont on comprend qu'elle
subit de violence et vous écrivez ça
sert à quoi de déposer plainte ça donne
un logement et qui peut croire qu'on
peut te protéger à l'intérieur de chez
toi s'il ya un endroit où personne ne
peut rien pour toi c'est bien chez toi
c'est impossible de protéger les femmes
contre la venise des hommes il n'est pas
impossible de protéger les femmes
simplement il faut prendre le problème
par ses différents bon bout alors
comment les prothèses justement ces
femmes aujourd'hui on les protège en
posant de la façon la plus claire et la
plus définitive le fait qu' il est
intolérable et non tolérée dans la
société que des violences aient lieu
dans au domicile conjugal que des
violences aient lieu d'une façon
générale contre les femmes est tolérable
ça veut dire les conditions
effectivement de recueil de plainte ça
veut dire aussi la possibilité de
repérer les premiers les premiers union
à parle de nyon dans cette nouvelle la
possibilité de ne pas se contenter d'une
explication je me suis cogné dans un
dans un mur où j'ai dévalé un escalier
si notre génération se débarrasse du
sentiment de honte qui est complètement
et du met qui travaillent les femmes
lorsqu'elles sont frappées elles ont
honte donc elles préfèrent mentir et
puis elles n'ont pas de perspective
lorsque je dis dans la nouvelle ça sert
à quoi d'aller porter plainte est ce que
ça donne un logement ça veut dire en
clair que il suffit pas de porter
plainte moi même j'ai fait une
circulaire pour demander que toutes les
plaintes fasse l'objet d'une
transmission au procureur de la
république qu'on ne se contente plus des
mains courantes donc oui j'appelle à
porter plainte
mais à quoi sert la place derrière et
c'est pas simplement que le procureur
l'instruit ou pas c'est à quoi sert la
plainte si on n'apporte pas des réponses
à tout ce qu'induit le fait de porter
plainte c'est à dire de devenir plus
vulnérables de provoquer plus de rage
chez l'homme qui frappe de ne pas avoir
deux solutions soit pour s'en aller de
ne pas savoir quoi faire de ses enfants
si on n'a pas de solutions justement
pour les faire accueillir de réfléchir
au fait que les enfants peut-être seront
obligés de changer d'école il y a dans
toute une série de conséquences et ne
suffit pas de dire aux femmes de porter
plainte parce que lorsque les femmes
sont frappés lorsqu'elles sont battues
elles sont dans un état de vulnérabilité
maximales elles sont fragilisées
émotionnellement elles sont souvent
fragiles du point de vue économique
elles sont tiraillés en tant que mère de
famille en tant qu'épouse elles sont
aussi blessés en tant que femme
amoureuse donc il faut apporter des
réponses à tout cela l'année dernière en
2020 ministère de l'intérieur a recensé
102 féminicide annoncé que 35 % de ces
femmes victimes avaient déjà subi des
violences et que 67% d'entre elles
avaient justement déjà signalé ces faits
de violences aux forces de l'ordre alors
on a eu des mesures on a eu 1 des
annonces grenelle contre les violences
conjugales pourtant à chaque nouveau
féminicide moi j'ai l'impression que ça
monte les défaillances de notre système
est ce qui est une mesure qu'on pourrait
poindre qui n'a pas été déjà prises en
tout cas ça c'est une mesure terrifiante
de l'échec général terrifiante et c'est
au risque de me répéter c'est que on ne
met pas en on ne fait pas converger les
réponses à tout ce qu'induit le fait
d'être frappés et de devoir être protégé
donc lorsque la femme dépose plainte
s'il n'ya pas de réponse immédiate
en est on a grandi le danger en
intensifie les dangers qu'il faut
apporter des réponses à toutes ces
choses là pas seulement si on améliore
l'accueil par exemple dans les
commissariats et les gendarmeries
on a apporté une réponse ne les a pas
toutes apporté si on facilite l'accès à
un hébergement en apporter une réponse
supplémentaire mais on n'a pas tout
apporté si l hébergement qu'il n'ya pas
l'indépendance économique n'ya pas
l'autonomie économique parce que la
personne est hébergée peut-être dans un
lieu lointain y compris pour la protéger
et qu'elle ne soit plus accessible à
l'homme violent quelle est sa situation
si elle avait déjà un emploi est ce
qu'elle peut le conserver et c'est donc
il faut
on aura tout cela et je pense que la
société est en capacité de répondre à
tout cela plutôt que de laisser
s'aggraver le nombre de féminicide je
vais aborder une autre thématique avec
vous c'est celle de la mémoire et
c'était aussi pour moi l'occasion de
parler d'une loi donc vous êtes à
l'origine qui a fêté ses 20 ans cette
année qu'elle a fait de la france le
premier pays à reconnaître l'esclavagé
et la traite comme un crime contre
l'humanité au delà du symbole comment
est-ce qu'on applique ces types de loi
aujourd'hui et je voudrais avoir votre
regard aussi sur la question de ce clash
pourquoi c'est un sujet toujours aussi
sensible aujourd'hui en france ah oui
c'est une loi qui contient une force
symbolique absolument incontestable
c'est justement dans la proclamation
solennelle par la parole officielle du
fait que la treille à l esclavage qui
étaient autorisées à l'époque c'était
pratique est autorisée par des lois
d'état par des décrets par des lettres
patentes et c'est que cela constitue un
crime contre l'humanité donc c'est un
acte solennel qui a beaucoup de force et
qui est conforme aux valeurs
républicaines donc que la république
puisse dire que ce que pratiqué la
monarchie était un crime c'est
effectivement un symbole extrêmement
important ça n'est pas que ça dans cette
loi il ya des dispositions tout à fait
normal il est notamment l'article 2 sur
l'enseignement de cette histoire et les
articles suivants qui par exemple
établissent la nécessité d'une date de
commémoration nationale c'est à dire le
fait de collectivement prendre en charge
cette partie de l'histoire dure écart de
plus de deux siècles et demi pour la
france quatre siècles et demi pour
l'ensemble des puissances européennes
qui ont pratiqué la traite négrière et
l'esclavagé
donc voila nous prenons ensemble on
charge cette histoire nous nous
souvenons ensemble le dit mais cela date
qui a été choisi en tout cas la loi créé
l'obligation de choisir une date et un
comité national pour la mémoire et
l'histoire de l'esclavagé qui fait des
propositions pour des actes de mémoire
c'est une partie de notre histoire qu'il
pose le plus problème aujourd'hui alors
cette histoire est l'histoire de la
colonisation sont d'étranges histoires
qui pose beaucoup de problèmes et qui
sont douloureuses parce qu'elles sont
porteuses d'une violence inouïe donc il
ya des personnes qui ont très très peur
de regarder sans face je me suis
beaucoup battu pour cet article 2 parce
que ma crainte mon angoisse c'était que
enfants les adolescents découvrent cette
histoire tout seul tout seul comme moi
je les découvertes tout seul tout seul
et c'est le pire c'est le pire alors moi
j'ai dit pendant plusieurs années comme
l'avait pas enseigner du tout et un jour
j'ai eu un déclic j'ai réalisé qu'on
m'avait enseigné le commerce
triangulaire
mais c'était juste le commerce
triangulaire donc je me rappelle de la
carte je me rappel voilà je me rappelle
puis les esclaves ça me paraissait
complètement abstrait plus qu'un film
car antoine exactement exactement et moi
c'est vraiment un déclic aller plusieurs
années après et j'ai donc cesser de dire
comme la pensée nier mais voilà comme on
l'a enseigné à ma génération
donc il faut que ce soit enseigné à vous
aussi c'est vous dire si vous dire parmi
les personnes qui n'acceptent pas cette
histoire moi je peux entendre les
personnes qui en sont gênés qui sont qui
veulent pas qu'ils disent mais c'est le
passé on veut plus en parler tu sais je
suis je peux comprendre oui c'est du
déni du déni et puis vous avez des
personnes qui ont reçu cette histoire
parce que ça ne les choque pas
foutez nous la paix avec cette histoire
parce que bon voilà à quoi c'était le
passé mais c'est le même genre de
personne qu'il recommencerait
aujourd'hui il y en a moi je me souviens
des débats à l'assemblée nationale en
2005 donc quatre ans après la loi sur la
fameuse loi de
février 2005 qui avoue connaît les
bienfaits de la colonisation
moi j'ai entendu des parlementaires à la
tribune en termes de valeur et de
référence ce n'était pas spécialement
choquée par les violences de la
colonisation donc ça n'aurait pas été ce
sont les mêmes qui contestent le fait de
prendre en charge ensemble l'histoire de
la traite négrière de l'esclavagé et ce
qu'il faut retirer des statuts de
l'espace public pour aller justement par
ce devoir de mémoire et cette
préparation on entend beaucoup parler
qui va souvent de pair avec le devoir de
mémoire alors personnellement je
n'utilise pas tellement le concept du
devoir de mémoire
parce que ça n'est pas une corvée quand
on voulait vous loupé à un appartement
par pur racisme ça complique votre vie
très sérieusement quand vous êtes dans
un moment de fragilité vous recherchez
du travail au logement etc et quand vous
insulte quand vous claque la porte au
nez qu'on ne vous répond pas au bout de
200 demandes d'emploi ce sont des
réalités dans la vie des gens donc il
s'agit de comprendre d'où ça vient tout
ça pourquoi ce existe aujourd'hui encore
donc ce n'est pas un devoir de mémoire
pour dire eux bon voila moi j'ai un
samedi libre là je vais voir si je rends
hommage à des ancêtres ces passages
sujet c'est qu'ils sont nous devenons
nous pourquoi la société telle qu'elle
est pourquoi il ya des catégories de
personnes voilà d'apparence différentes
pourquoi la france même en tant que
nation à ce rapport très particulier
très ambiguë avec des pays d'afrique
avec certains pays d'asie avec certains
pays d'amérique du sud ou d'amérique
centrale donc c'est quand même ça le
sujet fait comprendre c'est pas drôle
c'était en vie c'est pas une fantaisie
de devoir de mémoire il ya des gens il
ya des méditants pour eux voilà c'est un
devoir de mémoire ils ont raison et à la
question des morts sans sépulture ya la
question des noms qui ont été attribués
aux esclaves après l'abolition avec
beaucoup de fantaisie parfois il ya
toute une série de sujets qui justifie
effectivement un positionnement
militants mais il n'ya pas que ça il y à
là la question centrale c'est comment
comprendre notre société comment on
comprend certaines pensions comment on
comprend un certain blocage et certaines
agressions
absolument ça produit des inégalités
sans produit très directement donc
c'est ça le sujet vous avez du yen pour
cet entretien comme beaucoup d'autres
territoires ultramarins la biennale a
été sévèrement touchée par l'épidémie
coville 19 voilà quelque chose qui me
heurte beaucoup quand je lis l'actualité
en ce moment j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
deux situations sanitaires en france il
ya celles de métropole et la scène dans
les territoires ultramarins c'est vrai
il ya deux situations il ya deux
réalités aujourd'hui en france mais
c'est absolument indiscutable oui à deux
réalités alors il ya deux réalités dans
le domaine de la santé publique il y en
a deux dans le domaine de l'éducation de
l'accès à l'éducation pour les enfants
les ados et et les post ado il y en a
deux pour l'accès à l'emploi pour
l'accès à l'information il y en a deux
pour les libertés ordinaire et il y en a
deux pour les potentialités mesa au
service de la jeunesse est bon voilà il
y a ce sont des territoires
dont on dit alors qu'ils sont des
départements depuis 1946 il faut savoir
entre parenthèses par exemple que le
smic n'a été aligné dans les territoires
d'outre-mer dans les départements
d'outre-mer qu'au début des années 2000
d'accord quand même voilà voilà donc il
y a des éléments tout à fait tangibles
repérable mesurable qui prouve que il y
a des des rythmes d'application de la
loi qui sont différents
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
prennent pas en considération
la réalité géographique physique
sociologique historique géopolitique
aussi parce qu'ils sont pas dans l'air
un même si on les inscrit n'importe où
dans la carte 1 parce qu'il ya des
cartes c'est une connerie adopté alors
j'ai bataillé toute la nuit contre cette
connerie là où l'assemblée nationale
j'ai pas réussi à l'empêcher donc que
l'assemblée a adopté l'autorisation de
sur une carte de france 2 met à côté les
départements d'outre-mer on veut
déboussoler les gamines et les gamins
quoi on va les déboussoler leur dire que
voilà c'est juste à côté non c'est pas à
côté ça dix mille kilomètres donc si on
dit département et puis on regarde de
rien d'autre on a pu la loi aveuglément
ça n'a pas de sens et de toute façon
c'est plus loin ça râle - quand ça râle
ça dérange moins donc ça c'est moins
efficace et de sorte que en ce moment ce
que nous payons c'est un sou équipements
en matière de santé publique l'état des
hôpitaux le nombre de services les
effectifs les conditions de recrutement
les investissements qui vont tu fais
absolument voilà sous-équipement donc on
nous apporte des solutions ponctuelles
en on voit la réserve sanitaire en
envoient des militaires on décide de
mettre un petit hôpital de campagne
pendant quelques semaines c'est juste du
bricolage mais il y à là la preuve
évidente manifeste criante qu'il ya
inégalité en termes d'accès à la
citoyenneté qui a inégalité de
traitement et que ce sous équipement
chronique en matière de service public
fait que
l'élève ressortissants d outre-mer sont
plus plus exposés aux maladies
l'analphabétisme au chômage et c'est
plus exposés que la moyenne nationale ce
matin en amont de votre venue on a lancé
un appel aux questions sur nos réseaux
sociaux à notre communauté est une
question qui est beaucoup beaucoup
revenus est ce que vous allez candidat
tant donné le 22 c'est ce que tout le
monde a demandé ce matin sur les réseaux
sociaux oui mais je pense que moi je
comprends je comprends je vois bien le
mouvement depuis qui s'intensifie depuis
un an
oui je sais enfin je sais peut-être pas
tout tous
mes
mais c'est vraiment la question un peu
difficile de ma vie ce sa question la
plus difficile il ya un enjeu rapide et
déjà dire maintenant je suis pas
candidate vous arrêter tout ça un
terrain
c'est une dynamique qui appartient aux
personnes qui l'ont lancé aux personnes
qui la met en oeuvre et qui l'alimentent
ce que je peux dire c'est que moi je
prends la politique extrêmement au
sérieux et que le sérieux c'est que
bon voilà je pense que la situation
politique est extrêmement inquiétante
qu'elle est extrêmement exigeante en ce
moment et ce qu'elle existe et pas
simplement à moi aussi j'y vais elle
existe elle exige beaucoup plus que ça
elle existe que celles et ceux qui
prétendent exercer le pouvoir
se donne à la fois le temps les moyens
s'impose aussi les efforts pour apporter
les réponses qui conviennent à la
période actuelle la période actuelle est
très très inquiétantes sur le plan
national elle l'est beaucoup sur le plan
européen elle et elle est très
angoissantes sur le plan mondial et ça
se fait pas avec des avec des clichés
avec des réponses toutes faites avec
avec des analyses éculés ça c'est pas
avec ça ça c'est pas et que ça et
quelles que soient les qualités
individuelles y compris les miennes y
compris les miennes sont pas des choses
qui sortent de la tête d'une personne ou
d'une petite équipe c'est pas la hauteur
c'est pas la hauteur du rendez-vous
actuel voilà